الانجليزيه على خطى زيدان في ريال مدريد
الرئيسيه تدخلوا لمنع رحيل مبابي
والدوري الانجليزي يواصل تحطيم الارقام
التسويقيه
[موسيقى]
جود احدث صفقات ريال مدريد في الصيف
الحالي اختار رقما مميزا عقب انتقاله الى
نادي العاصمه الاسبانيه الشاب الانجليزي
فضل ارتداء الرقم خمسه وهو رقم الاسطوره
زين الدين زيدان وشهدت قائمه ريال مدريد
صغيره عده لاعبين لارقامهم على غرار
فينيسيوس جونيور الذي اختار الرقم 7 الخاص
بالنجمين السابقين
وكريستيانو رونالدو
اكد رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون انه
سيحاول التدخل بشكل شخصي للضغط على نجم
البلاد كيليان مبابي وابقائه ضمن صفوف
نادي سان جيرمان مبابي قد صرح في وقت سابق
بانه لن يفعل بلده تجديد لعام الاضافي مع
النادي الفارسي وكان مطروح قد تدخل في
الصيف الماضي شخصيا لاقناع مبابي بتجديد
عقده مع سنجرما وهو ما حدث فعلا
الهدف التاريخي لمنتخب انجلترا احتفل بهذا
الانجاز بطريقه مميزه خلال معسكر الاسود
الثلاثه مهاجم توتنهام موزعه ما يشبه
الاقراص الكلاسيكيه على زملائه تحمل كل
الاهداف التي سجلها مع انجلترا كما اضاف
رساله خاصه باسم كل لاعب من الفريق وتجاوز
كان رقم 1 روني خلال مباراه ايطاليا التي
لعبت شهر مارس الماضي بعدما وصل رصيده الى
55 هدفا في 82 مباراه
كشفت رابطه الدوري الانجليزي عن عائدتها
لموسم
2021-2022 والتي سجلت خلالها رقما قياسيا
بعائدات بلغت خمسه ملايير وخمسمائه مليون
باوند اي اكثر باثنته عشره بالمئه عن
الموسم الذي سبق وتمثل هذه العائدات ضعف
عائده لك الاسبانيه التي سجلت ملياري و800
مليون باوند واستفدت الانديه من عوده
الجماهير بعد الجائحه كورونا لتسجل اكثر
من مليار باوند من بيع التذاكر بينما بلغت
عائلته الاعلانات 320 مليون باوند
[موسيقى]